Speaker 1: Failed. Former President Donald Trump
is now under criminal investigation for espionage.
Yes, violations of the Espionage Act. My,
how quickly political fortunes can turn.
Two weeks ago, Joe Biden's presidency was very
stagnant. Record low approval rating. Donald Trump
seemingly coasting to a probable 2024 Republican
presidential nomination, seemingly unable to be
touched. And in a two week period on the Joe Biden
side, blockbuster jobs report, just extraordinary.
Inflation down, wages up. Passing the Pact Act,
passing the Inflation Reduction Act. And on the
other hand, Donald Trump now subject to an FBI
search warrant executed at his home in Florida
with multiple, multiple different criminal
investigations taking place. Let's take it
step by step. We will get to possible prison time
a little bit later in the show. But to start with,
the FBI search warrant has leaked and it
shows that Donald Trump is under investigation
for potential obstruction of justice and, yes,
Espionage Act violations. And we will look at
the details of that. Trump criminality going
radioactive. A search warrant unsealed Friday
reveals that the FBI is investigating Donald
Trump for potential violation of the Espionage Act
and that agents removed classified documents
from the former president's Florida estate
earlier this week. A receipt accompanying the
search warrant shows Trump possessed documents,
including a handwritten note documents marked with
TSC II, which is the highest one of the highest
levels of government classification, and another
item labeled info regarding the President of
France. The executive grant of clemency for
Roger Stone was in those items. The warrant shows
federal law enforcement was investigating Trump
for removal or destruction of records, obstruction
of justice, and violating the Espionage Act, which
can encompass crimes beyond spying, such as the
refusal to return national security documents
upon request, conviction under the statutes can
result in imprisonment or fines. Now, one of the
things that has also developed over the weekend
is a seemingly impossible to unwind series
of claims about whether or not the documents
were even at Mar a Lago. And it's beyond our
ability to unpack it today. And quite frankly,
it's not even the most interesting part of the
story, but I should, in order to be thorough,
mention that endlessly conflicting claims have
been made. First it was there were no documents,
then it was the FBI planted the documents, then
it was the documents were there, but they were
returned by June. So then they must have been
planted, or maybe not. And then it became, yeah,
the documents were there and it was completely
fine and legal for the documents to be there.
It's a witch hunt going after Trump for something
which isn't even a crime. Then it was. Well,
I declassified the documents. They were there,
but I declassified them even though there's no
evidence that they were declassified. And then
Trump claimed, Well, I had a standing order that
anything I take home gets declassified, which is
not how declassification works. It is an endless
mishmash a gish gallop, a throwing ketchup,
for lack of a better term, at the wall to see
what will stick and where we are at the end is
with the unsealed warrant. Now, the knowledge
that part of this investigation is into Trump
for possible violations of the Espionage Act,
not literal spying, but a number of crimes that
fall under the general umbrella espionage. Well,
so if you are for law and order and
there is an investigation going on
into an individual for the violation of particular
laws, what do you say? Well, if you're Rand Paul,
you say cancel the Espionage Act. It's
unbelievable. Let's talk about that next.